so I read a statistic the other day
apparently from the United Nations that
every year 800,000 people commit suicide
on a global scale that is a larger
number than the amount of people that
die in armed conflict and natural
disasters combined so what that means is
that the horrors of war and the horrors
of climate change while horrific no
doubt do not compare in number to the
amount of people that choose to commit
suicide every year through an act of
volition and agency sentence themselves
to death what is wrong with this picture
what kind of cancer has hijacked
consciousness as I Jack our amygdala to
make people's very selves be their
biggest threat biggest risk factor I
mean the implications are horrific I
mean we've already been told that
depression and anxiety are being
diagnosed at epidemic levels that there
is a fundamental fracture in our
collective psyche that our hunger for
meaning our desire for cosmic heroism
what Tolstoy said is man's inability to
live without a way to bridge the finite
with the infinite is severely under
threat we don't have faith anymore in
large numbers we don't have a connection
with something larger than ourselves
most of us are failing to have any
meaningful mystical experiences we are
starved for deeper meaning and
significance we are seekers hungry for
something else
and yet we can't seem to find what we're
looking for
there's a great line from the book of
the moviegoer that says the search is
what anyone would undertake they were
not sunk in the everydayness and the
gravity and the swamp of their own lives
to merely become aware the possibility
of the search is to be on to something
not to be on to something is to be in
despair and so I think today this is our
crisis our societies our cities our
social structures are organized in a way
that is oppressive to way too many of us
it does not allow for acts of cosmic
heroism does not allow for symbolic
slaying of the dragon some people are so
poor all they have is money so I think
we need to rethink this whole picture of
how we organize our lives come back come
out with better kind of symbolic
structures that allow our psyches to
merge with some higher meaning so that
our lives can stand for something this I
think could be our cure
you
[Music]